in today's video we're gonna be writing
different graphics from the absolute
worst texture packs all the way up to
the most hyper realistic graphics
imaginable it'll be like we're there and
we're gonna kick things off with the
worst graphics you've ever seen
whoa
welcome to the world's dumbest graphic
wait it hurts my brain oh my gosh i'm
gonna throw up wait look at how the
villagers look all of the animals look
like they've seen something super bad
this cow looks bewildered
jimmy look another portal bro this looks
like doritos with water this texture
pack was made for me i want minecraft to
be like this maybe call me dumb okay
dumb gentlemen on a scale of one to ten
how much would you like to play with
this texture pack i gave it a six ten i
got a headache from this i'm giving it a
zero i'm giving it a three next
welcome to the second texture pack whoa
this is 10 000 times better i wish i
could walk on those grass in real life
jimmy look you can see every leaf that's
cool oh let's check hey check out the
house let's go check out the homes
oh wait a second guys look the fire's
still exactly the same that's lazy
oh look at that pool oh look at the
water oh my gosh the water is insane
it's an infinity pool voice everyone
rate it i'll give it a six i give it a
six i give it a seven i was gonna give
it a seven two jimmy 26 out of 40 next
texture pack surfer drop the veil
texture pack number three um listen it
has character that's not the reaction i
need i love this texture pack
bro these creepers have gills notice
that the mobs are textured oh my
goodness look at the villagers their
faces are so cursed i'll be honest this
texture pack's a little mid the thing
about this one is it's very attention to
detail oriented everything looks like it
fits together it has heart is it winning
though on a scale of one to ten of what
i play it i don't know if this is in the
depth bro it's so bright come on
give it a chance let's all radio at the
same time
which added up to this number which is
below the other number next pack server
dropped the veil
whoa okay it looks like an old video
game
zoom in on these rocks look at the
detail i i might give this higher than i
thought originally half of me really
likes this and then half of me feels
like it looks too realistic it looks
almost good
well let's see what a creeper looks like
creeper oh what yo i don't like its
heart in there and it's like dead grass
oh my god the cow
look at his face
ew what on earth is going on with this
villager this villager looks like sapnam
hello so we're testing out a texture
pack and the villagers are really ugly
carl said they look like you what do you
want to say to him carl's stupid really
bad at video games
honestly carl you should just uninstall
that's fair
uh what do you guys rate it seven point
five i'll give it a seven eight carl
what do you write it
carl ran away trailer if you were carl
what would you rate it four plus three
which equals 29.5 so this is now in the
lead next hey chris you like cats i love
them perfect because battlecats is
sponsoring this video and if you can win
this battle by the end of the ad read
i'll give your newest ticktock follower
10 grand all right the battle begins the
battlecaps is a tower defense mobile
game where you can recruit an army of
weirdly cute cats to smash the enemy
base before they destroy yours jimmy
there's so many cats on my screen cat
with a chainsaw they're celebrating
eight years since release until october
10th all you have to do is visit the
rare capsule machine for a chance to
unlock uber rare cats i like the cats
with the big thick thighs how are you
doing i'm a third away from beating it
you can then take your cats and conquer
earth the universe and time itself
download battlecast 43 on apple or
google play by scanning this qr code or
using the links in the description
hey i just won your newest ticket
follower just won 10 grand thanks for
following me that person server fail
drop
welcome to the next texture pack this
kind of hurts my eyes it's bright like
my future
the first thing we have to see is a
panda
nothing new on the panda not gonna lie
jimmy that's gonna be points off for
me holy cow the sand bleeds into the
block next to it it's super realistic
look at this rock it has 3d definition i
could stare at this forever
[Music]
oh there's a pirate ship i didn't even
see that
oh
the crafting table looks incredible they
have like tools on the side of them
gentlemen we need to go ahead and rate
these graphics because we still have
much more they get way better oh wait
jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy the grass
wiggles it does that normal minecraft
yeah they always do do they no look it
has like you're actually an idiot well
now that the grass has embarrassed me i
give it a four i'd give it a 7.5 i'm
gonna add some points to make up for
chris i give it an eight i'll give it an
eight also i think the 3d is cool 27.5
not first place next pack welcome to the
next texture pack
let's go
oh my god this is perfect minecraft i
can feel the texture oh my god i love
this it looks like star wars legos
everything is lego look at the fire on
the skeleton oh listen when you break
logs
oh
wait let's go look at this boat
oh my god wait the boats are legos look
at this lego water
the millennium vulcan it is lego star
wars the build isn't part of the texture
pack but hey your mom is
[Music]
oh jimmy tp to me
the smoke is legos the smoke is legos
wow that is cool look at the fire
boys we have one final test we must blow
up the titanic and see if it's legos
oh my gosh oh
that sounds so cool that that's a 10 now
i'm giving it an eight it's a 10. 7.8
35.8 which now puts it in first next one
and now for the final and most epic
graphic pack of all are you ready i'm
excited i'm eating jesus welcome to
hyper realistic minecraft
what is this it's just so pretty it's so
fun to walk around when you have
graphics like this
jimmy wait there's a circle in minecraft
what the heck because there's circles in
real life how is this minecraft
chris look at the windows look at the
condensation on it
i love this
oh my god jimmy come in here
what wait no way we're still in
minecraft i'm getting seasick
i'll take this house in real life i'll
buy it but look
we talked about mobs being such a big
thing none of the mobs work yeah what
the heck all right server make it dark
oh what whoa
the leds
[Music]
fly around the city at night time it's
so beautiful it definitely added a lot
i'm grabbing the microphone it's getting
serious out of 10 what do you rate it
chris 8.2 carl 8.2
chandler i'm gonna give it a solid eight
well now my vote doesn't matter because
even if i give it a 10 it still loses
the legos so everyone the greatest
texture pack is the lego texture pack
lego over luxury yippee
subscribe or i will murder